okay good afternoon i'm assistant
sheriff brett zimmerman and i'm here to
brief you on additional details
as we know them today about the officer
involved shooting that occurred on
wednesday february 3rd
2021. this is ois number one
for 2021 fatal number one and at the
same time last year
we were at ois number two and zero of
those were fatal at that time
the date time and type of call was
february 3rd 2021
at 11 59 a.m and it was an attempt grand
larceny
the location of the ois was fifth the
5900 block
of dean martin drive las vegas nevada
89118 which is in the spring valley area
command
and you can see the scene of the map to
my left
our involved officer is officer andrew
nguyen and i'll spell that it's
n g u y
e n pronounced win
he is 34 years old and has been with
lvmpd since
2018. in this incident officer wynn was
armed with a glock
model 45 nine millimeter handgun
equipped with a tactical light
the investigation revealed he fired nine
rounds during the incident
our suspect is a marvan payton jr
spelling is up there he's a 27 year old
black male adult
5 feet 11 tall and weighs 170 pounds
his criminal history mr payton does have
a criminal history of being violent with
police officers which include the
following charges
attempt murder in north las vegas pd
battery on a protected person north las
vegas pd
attempt robbery of a firearm north las
vegas pd an assault on a protected
person
and all of those incidents were violence
against the police
our suspect's weapon he was armed with a
screwdriver
mr peyton's charges had he survived the
incident was attempt murder on a
protected person
attempt grand larceny with a of a
firearm
and resisting a public officer with
deadly weapon
details of the ois on wednesday february
3rd
2021 at approximately 11 59 a.m
the lvmpd dispatch center received an
attempted grand larceny call
at a gun range located at the 5900 block
of dean martin drive the person
reporting
stated that a black male adult later
identified as marvon payton
had tried to steal a gun that was inside
a customer's back
the caller stated the employees would be
standing by with mr payton
outside upon the officer's arrival
at approximately 12 27 pm dispatch was
called again
and advised that mr payton was now
becoming aggressive
and had threatened the employees
officer wynn and his partner arrived in
the parking lot of the business
approximately 12
47 p.m and attempted to contact mr
payton
officer wynn and his partner instructed
mr payton to stand in front of their
patrol vehicle
mr payton ignored those instructions and
started to walk away
while hiding his right hand in his
jacket pocket
officers attempted to grab mr payton but
he pulled away and still refused to
listen to the officers
officers attempted to grab mr payton by
his arms once again to gain control of
him
this time mr payton pulled away and
produced a screwdriver
from his pocket and violently attacked
the officers
mr payton made several overhand strikes
with the screwdriver
towards one of the officers head and
neck area
mr payton was able to stab one officer
during his violent attack
as the injured officer fell to the
ground officer wynn
and three employees of the business
discharged their firearms striking mr
payton
officers immediately summoned medical
personnel but mr payton succumbed to his
injuries at the scene
through the course of the investigation
it was learned that mr payton went into
the gun range
and walked around the maiden lobby then
proceeded
to the concealed carry weapons classroom
ccw the students were taking a break in
the classroom when mr payton entered the
room and began
rifling through a bag which contained a
handgun that belonged to one of the
students
the owner of the bag was able to prevent
the gun from being stolen and mr payton
was escorted out of the classroom at
that time
an employee spoke to mr payton for
several minutes trying to figure out
what he was doing
in the gun range a short time later
another employee called police to report
the attempted grand larceny
three employees escorted mr payton
outside of the business
and waited for officers to arrive at
this time
i will now show you surveillance video
from the officer involved shooting
this first video is actually from the
classroom and mr payton
is sitting he's right here wearing a
black and yellow jacket
and a bag is underneath of one of the
students and again they were on
break at that time so everybody was
coming back into the classroom during
from the from the class break
uh
and then this here is the actual
uh video surveillance video from the
business
in which the uh shows the officer's
arrival and the actual ois
and he's standing down here at the lower
portion of the screen
okay there any questions
sir just to get the the timing correct
the original call was 11 59
and there was a secondary call later
on
correct so basically what it what with
the way our calls work is
originally the original call was he was
in the business
in that timeline creating whatever
disturbance he was creating
i don't think all the information was
gathered at first that he had gone
through someone's bag in the classroom
and then we prioritized the calls in
regards to a violent type of call where
up until our arrival the individual was
not violent he was outside with those
employees they were kind of standing
there
waiting for the police to arrive of
course
i i don't know we didn't get that depth
into an interview with them don't know
if he knew the police were coming
but they were outside waiting on us the
employees
and like i said with our call priority
stuff we usually go on a violent type
call first if one's created
but something like that where the
suspect seems cooperative the business
isn't saying he's become
agitated and at some point during that
time frame they said he was getting more
aggressive and that's when the units
went enroute over there yes sir
clearly these three employees likely
knew
yeah it seems that obviously when you go
into a gun range or a gun store most of
their employees are trained pretty
trained to the t they're armed usually
and uh
you know they either instruct firearm
classes there or they protect the
protect the gun store uh all i can say
here is we do our own internal
investigation on our employees
first and then from from what i'm
judging or what i saw what everybody saw
in the video
their training and tactics were kind of
along the line of our officer
they saw the same threat our officer
fired they fired at about the same time
threat saw exactly what occurred just
like you all did with the violent
strikes to the officer's face
with what originally was unknown if it
was a knife it had come out that it was
a knife
it turned out to be a screwdriver but
they saw the same thing our officer saw
in regards to the threat
and an officer either being injured or
killed by that individual
it was a coleman i would have to the
coroner usually makes that call but
the suspect was struck numerous times so
usually you can't make that
determination but i would say
uh i don't know which which actually
which bullet killed him but he was
struck numerous times so
i guess later on what'll happen after
our case is done
it'll go to the da's office for our own
internal case the da then takes a look
at that case
involving the civilians which again
looking at the video they saw the same
thing our officer saw
there was approximately they removed 14
rounds from him
and how many rounds did an officer
officer win fired
nine rounds i believe okay
the officers were equipped with cameras
they were not on
and it was usually due to the fact they
they are trained to activate their
cameras but as they pull up to the
businesses individuals
right outside there didn't have time to
turn the camera on and you see how quick
the incident occurred where the second
they got out of the car he started
pulling away
walking away within i'd say 15 to 30
seconds so
under that circumstance the cameras were
not on and that's something we look at
internally from our investigation
as to why why they weren't turned on
immediately um is that something that
could result in discipline
usually in regards to not turning your
camera on
uh the initial time they do it we do
something we treat it as
it's performance related and in regards
to these officers who are on scene
they have a very we look at everything
they had a very high
body worn camera activation rate in the
upper 90s percentile
of turning their cameras on so there
were no prior issues with these officers
now i'm not saying it's not going to
result in a
performance related uh you know
counseling type thing but
they we've had no instances of them not
turning their cameras on in the past
okay and uh who's the officer
it was one of our one of our officers we
don't release that information in
regards to
the victim officer on the call we only
release the shooter's information
on these calls yeah she
she is actually recovering she's doing
better
she had injuries to her head and to her
she had a fractured orbital uh area
around the eye from being struck but
she is actually on the path to recovery
and they were not
anything seri they were serious but not
life-threatening and she's she's
recovering
yes sir the dangers of you know
the work you know one second you're
trying to
kind of a mild call for a robbery but
then
for a second
you know we're pretty good at our
tactics and training and we teach
everybody no matter what time you have
on this agency that a call can go from
like you said routine
to critical within seconds this is
another type of call that officers could
get complacent
they probably handle 10 to 15 type calls
of this a week where there's a subject
outside of a business refusing to leave
could be homeless could be mentally ill
and
99 out of 100 times they're compliant
but it's the one time that they're not
compliant that something like this
occurs and it turns deadly but
we train from the start to never be
complacent and to always be tactically
sound
and you saw from this video and what
they did both officers exited the
vehicle
looked like they were giving commands to
the individual he starts walking away
one goes around as you see from the
video to try and box them in to get back
to the front of the car
and then from that point once starts
pulling away enough
hands on the tight they had to go
hands-on the type of call
up he's armed with something uh
originally a knife and and obviously
tried to steal a weapon
while inside the business yes sir
two questions uh one have you had a
situation
where this many citizens have been
involved
in a issue
i'm just going off my own personal
knowledge and my time on this agency i
can't remember
a time when when a citizen actually
fired a weapon
along with one of our officers on the
scene
i don't know you know like i said i
don't have the history of it
earlier in my career but since i've been
on staff you know six to ten years i
don't remember
an incident where we had this many
civilians also fire that were actually
armed through their type of business
that they were you know
we talk a employed at de-escalation
about mental illness
when you approach a scene like that are
officers trained on de-escalation
tactics and
did something escalate here or was this
kind of we train
we train on de-escalation each of our
officers takes a
cit class which is a required 40-hour
class it's basically a crisis
intervention class they're recertified
on the crisis intervention it means that
they go through this class to actually
deal with those type of situations to
deal with mentally ill persons
and they receive training above and
beyond just the most of the verbal stuff
you utilize with
with normal citizens or suspects to get
them to comply but
they're taught in a manner that they may
be dealing with someone in distress
somebody that's mentally ill
so they all all of our officers receive
this cit training
but like i said under this circumstance
it's obvious the guy had mental
some something wrong possibly mentally
and then for it to happen that quick
up and and i mentioned earlier his prior
violence with police officers you know
he he just in an instant wound up you
know attacking the officers seconds into
that
encounter did the citizens aren't they
save that officer's life if they were
obviously you had an officer there that
well trained what role did they play
i would i would say our officer along
with the citizen
citizens saved you know yes i would say
could
save that officer's life also the other
officer was in danger
uh wynn who also fired he was that close
because you didn't know if that suspect
was then going to turn on him
but yes you know be there there their
involvement actually
helped our officer and and could have
saved our officer's life
yes sir so what the citizens did
there's no legal question there they're
not facing the charges
uh what we what we do is we submit the
case on our officer to the district
attorney on any one of our oises where
it's a
obviously a fatal shooting after the d.a
makes determination on that with our
officer
we spoke we've already spoken to the d.a
they will then look at that case
in regards to any charges against the
civilians
but you know like i said in viewing this
video here
it's it's kind of obvious as to why why
the civilians fired and and also
you know civilians too are not as
tactically trained as our officers
they but they're seeing the same threat
that our officers saw there and and for
what you saw the initial part of this
video
the violent attacks and they don't know
how
what the injury to our officer was at
that time she actually fell on the
ground so
you know was she was she injured you
know was she more critically injured or
you know they don't know what this what
this suspect's going to do next is he
going to come back for another
round of stabbing but that's how it
works the d.a will
take a look at that and will decide
whether to
prosecute citizens uh
yes sir
right we we always if
on a call like that we're usually
pushing when we have enough
time we're pushing civilians back we
don't want civilians to get involved
when we
respond on a call our dispatchers are
trained to tell the
civilian if there's a gun in their house
to put the gun away all these protocols
that our dispatchers go
through originally and the officers will
ask them while enroute to the call
to make sure that that's been asked if
the dispatcher hasn't asked it
the other part of that too is that when
you're dealing with
incidents like this with with civilians
you could see initially they were off to
the side it didn't seem like they wanted
to get involved but when they saw what
occurred
that's when they took action but we we
want people to be as good of witnesses
as they can
now under circumstances when officers
out there by themselves and
an officer's in a knockdown drag out
fight with a with a
suspect in the street we've had citizens
come to our aid
and assist us under those circumstances
but it's only under those extreme
circumstances and that's what we preach
yes sir would your officers have had any
uh
any knowledge violent history with
police
as they were responding to that prior to
the shooting
i believe prior to the shooting
originally we didn't know who the
individual was
but at some point there was a uh there
there was some radio traffic in which
uh the they did identify the suspect i
believe the business owners had gotten
that information
through an id that he had but i don't
know how much
of i know some was passed on to the
officers but a lot of this stuff we find
out in detail we have to go back through
those reports and
look at the exact cases that this
suspect was involved in
because a lot of times when someone's
booked for a specific charge you don't
really have all those details as to what
what they're engaged in but there was
some criminal history exchanged over the
air i just don't know the exact
depth of what what it was and that was
prior to the shooting
correct so there were
three or four citizens involved there
were three citizens involved
and of the three three involved i
believe
or they were it looked like we had we
had two individuals who shot
and there was a gun range instructor who
didn't have a shot over the officer so
he he did not fire
but we had three people interviewed i
believe two were shooters of the
citizens and one did not fire
because of the issue with standing right
above the officer when the officer
fell and if you look at the when you see
the video there were two shooters from
the right
side and how many of those three total
shooters okay
i'm sorry there were three total
shooters three total shooters how many
rounds did the citizens fire
uh
when i was at the scene when i was at
the scene
i know all three fired i don't know have
the exact count on how many exact rounds
they had fired
and some of the issues were we don't
they don't have protocols on how
how to load their how many rounds are in
their magazines or weapon countdowns so
we don't have that exact amount
how many of your officers
i don't have that answer yet either okay
you're welcome